breaking news from our political
correspondents kate mccann kate what
have you got for us
good morning well in the last few
moments the labour party have released a
statement in which they've confirmed
that they have removed the whip from
jeremy corbyn i can read you that
statement
in light of his comments made today and
his failure to retract them subsequently
the labour party has suspended jeremy
corbyn pending investigation
he has also had the whip removed from
the parliamentary labour party
now that's a significant moment because
it's really the most
strict restriction or measure that the
current labor leader serkis dama can
take and it comes in the wake of a
statement that jeremy corbyn made this
morning
in relation to the report that we have
been discussing
in that statement jeremy corbyn said one
anti-semite is one too many but the
scale of the problem was also
dramatically overstated for political
reasons by our opponents
inside and outside the party as well as
by much of the media now that is the
specific comment
that this statement and the subsequent
uh removal of the wit from jeremy corbyn
relates to
and in fact he was asked in a press
conference earlier today kierstarma
whether he would take action
after what jeremy corbyn said and he
stated that he would look carefully at
those comments so now we are seeing that
follow-up action and really the the
this is a significant moment because mr
corbyn of course was in charge for much
of this period during the investigation
of this report
and in fact in the last few moments
jeremy corbyn himself has been speaking
to broadcasters here is a clip from that
interview
let's be clear start off one anti-semite
in the party is one anti-semite too
many and when i became leader of the
party
some complaints were received i asked
shami chakrabarti to undertake a review
of all this which she did
she made a number of recommendations on
processes which were not implemented
quickly enough
under jenny formby's period as general
secretary in 2018
much more progress was made very quickly
but the numbers
have been exaggerated in my view
the public perception in the opinion
poll last year was that one third of all
labour party members
were somehow or other under suspicion of
anti-semitism
the reality is it was 0.3
of party members had a case against them
which had to be put through the process
and so i think it's clear that we do not
accept
i do not accept kirsten does not accept
none of us accept anti-semitism
in any form whatsoever in our party
could your leadership have changed this
could you have done more
i did everything i could to make sure a
process was put in place and cases were
dealt with quickly
and as the report acknowledges in the
latter stages
the process had speeded up more cases
were dealt with
where necessary people were expelled
from the party but
also i think we could and should have
made more progress on the education
process because i do think
education into the hurt caused to jewish
people by allegations
of anti-semitism by anti-semitic tropes
and tweets and messages
is deep and horrible and i'm very sorry
for any people
that were hurt as a result of that
because i want to see like
everybody else does in the labor party
anti-semitism
completely ended kiyostama has said
today those who pretend this
is exaggerated or is factional are part
of the problem
you've told me today it is exaggerated
what i said today was
that anti-semitism is unacceptable in
any form
what i said was exaggerated
what i said was the numbers of cases in
the public perception had become
overstated the existence of the problem
i fully acknowledge which is why
i took action to end the problem in the
party by introducing a process
to get anti-semites out of the party
you use the word today with me
exaggerated kia stammer says those who
pretend
this is exaggerated or factional are
part of the problem
are you part of the problem mr corbin no
i'm not part of the problem
the problem is anti-semitism
historically anti-semitism
in the presence and the fear that many
people
have of being under attack at their
synagogue or indeed
mosques temples and lots of other places
within our society
we need to tackle racism in every
conceivable form
within our society but are you sorry
that
seemingly on this issue you failed to
tackle
i don't believe i did fail i believe
that i brought in the rules that were
necessary
and those are the ones that are now in
operation which means that the process
is much more rapidly dealt with but
let's be clear about this
racism is a poison and a cancer in our
society
we all have to oppose it all the time
everywhere
kistama said today anyone who claims
that this issue has been
exaggerated should be nowhere near the
labour party
will you resign from the party of course
not
i am proud to be a member of the labour
party i joined the labour party when i
was 16.
i fought racism all my life and i'll
fight racism for the rest of my life
and as leader of the party i did
everything i could to ensure that we
were
a leading anti-racist organization and
anti-racist party
the rise of racism in this country and
even worse across europe
is a serious scourge we have to unite
to protect all communities that are
under threat and unite
to ensure that racism becomes part of
history
not part of our presence and what do you
think of the people who are calling
today for you to resign
i ask them to think for a moment this
party is a
very big organization we come from
lots of different political trends and
backgrounds but we united
and our wish to have a unified society
free from racism we united in our
determination to bring about
economic justice we're appalled that a
million young people are without jobs at
the present time
surely these are the things that unite
us and we are united to get rid of the
scourge of racism